almost two-week-long siege in canada's
capital by truckers protesting pandemic
policies starting to be felt across the
border here in the u.s the auto industry
is particularly in peril correspondent
molly line in ottawa tonight
vowing these wheels won't turn until a
cross-border vaccine mandate is lifted
big rigs are firmly parked the ongoing
freedom convoy protests snarling traffic
to and from canada at the ambassador
bridge spanning from detroit to windsor
ontario where a ford plant was forced to
shut down windsor's mayor expressing
fears of long-term economic damage and
escalating tensions
these demonstrators are our fellow
canadians and that they have a
fundamental right to their views and
their opinions
they don't have the right to affect you
or your family's ability to earn a
living and they've gone too far the
bridge accounts for roughly 25 percent
of trade between the u.s and canada a
lot of auto parts will go over the
bridge have something done to them and
then they'll come back across to be
finished and you're really this is
really upsetting that whole free flow of
parts canadian prime minister justin
trudeau and u.s leaders are expressing
mirrored fears regarding the impact on
trade with democrat michigan governor
gretchen whitmer issuing a simple
message to canadian authorities
reopen traffic on the bridge noting
automotive manufacturing and agriculture
businesses are feeling the effects
one trucker looked at the politicians
and cried hypocrisy all these global
leaders have been hurting the supply
chain for the last two years and we're
just supporting if we have to live
without for the few borders closed for
now it will all be supporting that
because it's for a good cause hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else